oh my God
Wes is being so quiet I know he's being
so good if the kids aren't crying things
are good yeah
we got a Tailwind it's a paddler's dream
yeah just my concern is just the wind
past this point I know it's looking like
it's going to pick up a bit a little
wind is like a gale force but what do
you think about trying something out
like rigging up a sail is that to just
take more time than just paddling if I
could find the right materials we could
rig it up pretty quick and we're gonna
have to probably want to stop to feed
the kids anyways right if we're stopping
for lunch I suppose yeah you can try to
rig it up oh
what a nice little spot hey go on
Governor right into the rocks
oh honey you want some lunch hey hun can
I go grab a couple sticks to rig up the
sale sure okay I'll be back soon yep if
I don't come back never remarry
[Music]
you hear that
it is a little windy out there and so
I'm sure the sale would be a good idea
if the wind stays in our favor but if it
changes could be a little bit tricky
I'm gonna have to take a couple small
saplings so I don't just walk into the
woods and cut down the biggest perfect
tree standing right in the middle that's
a tree that's healthy that's going to
live for a long time so they're going to
take those from a spot where there's a
whole bunch growing close together in
that way if I take a couple and thin it
out more trees will live to become
mature trees
there we go I think that'll be just
about right
[Music]
pretty much what I think is the perfect
thing for the Mast yeah I am just
lashing up these two long whippy pieces
of sapling that is actually going to be
the top of the Mast yeah it's gonna be
pretty cool
[Music]
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
lash them to the gunnels by wrapping a
rope around the hall of the boat and
that's almost going to create like an
arch and then going to tie a camping
tarp to a stick
put a pulley in the top that way we can
drop the sail if it gets too windy so
we'll know that we'll be safe out there
as well
yeah
ready to set sail honey
you know it's a little upsetting that
huddy's asleep though and he hasn't
really soaked in the Brilliance of the
sail rig he'll have to enjoy the
pictures unless he wakes up we'll see
though yeah good boy okay okay you ready
okay let's do it
all right I'm gonna raise it all right
ah yeah it's working
this is great we're sailing
okay cross draw
I am I'll start with you crosstalk
we could technically sail all the way to
the end of this Bay effortlessly with
the Tailwind day I know I got my feet up
just saving energy it's saving time
we're doing it too bad the kids are both
asleep
we should get into sailing honey yeah
bam
[Music]